i think one of the scenes in the series
that fans are going absolutely wild for
is when selena meets a very young
beyonce
solange and tina knowles in the mall
hold your sister's hand
who are you looking at who's that selena
tell me what your reaction was to when
you saw that that was incorporated in
the script and what do you make of that
fun
little pop culture nugget oh i thought
it was so cool i thought it was so cute
and i thought
you know that's what this story is about
is inspiration and
inspiring young people to follow their
dreams whatever those dreams are and
i just thought that was such a cool
moment and i did the same thing everyone
else did did that really happen did that
really happen
um i think it did i did actually meet
selena in the galleria mall in houston
but i didn't say much to selena because
i wasn't a celebrity and i just saw her
and said hello and
kept it moving i think she
is a legend and i admire her and
she was so talented selena
who's selena i said who's selena
famous singer be quiet you're a singer
too talented
hi beyonce knows
you better learn not to be afraid of
people if you ever want to be famous
too now come on
i don't know i always make jokes about
if this means is this going to be my
connection to meeting beyonce i mean
girl
if we if we were deprived of the selena
beyonce
collab that you know would have been
fire yeah
i would love for you to finally have a
moment with beyonce that would be
unbelievable
okay well yeah let's all let's all put
that out in the universe
put it out there